Peter who was the Biggest Loser last
night besides the congressman's from the
7th district well certainly the
establishment the House Republican
leadership Tom and I would argue that a
lot of big business groups who have
contributed to Eric Cantor been closely
allied with Eric Cantor have counted on
Eric Cantor for big votes they were
losers last night as well but I think
right at the top of the list in addition
to day Eric Cantor time you got to put
House Speaker John Boehner he's got to
be looking over his back right now
worried very much about a challenge to
his own leadership position come next
year I have her you and your colleague
Phil Mattingly talk about an
establishment effort to bring the
Republicans away from the Tea Party can
they continue that well it took a big
hit last night with this defeat for Eric
Cantor but they've supported other
candidates and had more success in this
campaign season but Thomas is a huge
blow no question about it the biggest
blow by far and it raises real questions
about establishment Republicans or more
importantly House Republicans who want
to see themselves associated with big
business with the corporate cronyism
that's the the catchword right now
that's the risk for a lot of Republicans
they will be running away from the
Chamber of Commerce not towards the
Chamber of Commerce after this I want to
go right there Peter because the
Republican field keeps describing
Cantor's defeat as stunning right up
bratz victory was completely unexpected
so given all that what other upsets
should we be factoring in now well the
first and most obvious one is to watch
what happens in Mississippi with this
runoff between thad Cochran and a tea
party challenger there that was already
going to be an uphill fight we saw 44
thad Cochran this will give new energy
to the tea party organizers in
Mississippi they will see that as the
next scalp to grab for sure hey Peter
you mentioned that Speaker Boehner
position may be in question jeb
Hensarling out of Texas is he the guy
that people are looking towards as a
potential successor Adam as soon as this
news hit last night i was getting emails
and phone calls from people saying watch
jeb Hensarling he's a conservative here
fiscal conservative best known to a lot
of our viewers for his chairmanship of
the house financial services committee
he is someone who has been talked about
for a long time as someone who could
fight for a seat at the leadership
the question I have is if he does it
does he go for Cantor's job number two
within the leadership position or does
he mount a challenge to John Boehner
that's where all eyes will be starting
even this morning here on Capitol this
will start right away we will not wait
till next year for that to happen